Politicians should be on social media
because it's also their way
of connecting with people,
and they certainly have
a right to free speech.
So, I don't think it was easy for Meta
to decide whether Mr. Trump
should be taken down or not.
And we actually also touched
upon in our decision,
that Trump should not
be taken down because
he was saying falsehoods
about the election.
We only said that it was
right to take Mr. Trump down
because he was inciting violence.
Hello and welcome,
billions of posts, from billions of users,
political, social, and financial power
bigger than some nation states.
So, how do you oversee Facebook?
That job falls to the relatively new
Facebook Oversight Board
dubbed the social network's
so-called Supreme Court.
And my guest today is its
co-chair, Helle Thorning-Schmidt,
who was Denmark's first
female Prime Minister.
She led the center-left
Social Democrats Party
in a coalition and held that
post for four years until 2016.
Now, she's helping to
oversee the tech titan,
which operates under
the parent company Meta,
and also owns WhatsApp and Instagram.
So, can it really be held to account,
even by former world leaders,
professors, charity bosses,
and Nobel laureates?
At a time when the social network business
can block a U.S. president,
and as it tries to curb
COVID misinformation,
arguably, it's a more
important role than ever.
Helle Thorning-Schmidt, welcome.
Thank you very much.
Well, we'll get to that role shortly,
but I wanted to just come to something
which I find fascinating about you.
You were 48,
when you left the
biggest job of your life.
It's actually very interesting
because I think that us, prime ministers,
we've become younger and younger.
And that also means that we leave earlier.
Many former prime ministers,
they actually yeah, died on the job.
But we are a generation of politicians
that came into politics quite early,
and are also leaving quite early.
And that means that I was just before 50,
and had just to shake my head a bit
and find out what's there for me
for the rest of my working life.
And was extremely fortunate
that I got in contact
with Save the Children
International here in London,
and started talking to them
because they needed a new CEO.
And I took over that role,
and was so happy to start a new chapter
with something so meaningful
as working for children
all over the world.
Can you remember that the day after
you ended being Prime Minister?
I mean, did you just get
your jogging bottoms on,
your slippers, did you slob about?
What do you do?
It is so weird to stop
being Prime Minister.
And I think there's nothing
that compares to that.
You just, your whole life changes.
And I remember very clearly coming in,
hugging my chauffeurs and my,
the police that had been
helping me all the way through,
hug them goodbye outside my house,
walked in, closed the door behind me,
and quiet, just quiet.
No one phones you,
the office, the party, you're
used to people connecting
and talking to you all the time,
and stuff happening all the time.
And it was just quiet.
So, I remember that quiet.
It was a tristesse, not like a depression,
but a little bit of a situation where
you're not quite sure
how you live in this life
without all the buzz that was around you.
But I watched Game of Thrones for a month.
I got a...
For a month?
No, not really.
I got our bikes repaired so I
could bike round Copenhagen.
There are so many things
I hadn't done on my bike,
or just walking around Copenhagen.
That was my way of transitioning
into just being a normal person again.
So, you mentioned about
becoming the Chief Executive
of Save the Children
International, that came to an end.
And your next role,
which is as I was just
saying in my introduction,
it's such an important and pivotal moment
to have such a role,
is co-chair of this Facebook-
Yeah.
Oversight Board.
I just wanted to ask, first of
all, who asked you to do it?
And why did you want to do it?
Well, we all know that
social media has come up,
and has for a long, long
time been very unregulated.
And basically, what we saw was
that the ultimate decisions
about what content stays
up on social media,
or gets removed,
is taken by the social media
company companies themselves,
and ultimately, Mark Zuckerberg.
And somehow that doesn't feel right.
We need probably more
regulation on, of social media,
but it also seemed a
better way of doing it.
That Facebook was actually outsourcing
to an independent body,
how their content should be reviewed.
And so, basically the reason
why I took on the role
is because I consider the
Oversight Board independent.
Facebook has to listen to our decisions,
they have to follow our decisions.
And we also have this
opportunity to give them advice,
or recommendations of what
they should do on social media.
And it goes both for
Facebook, and for Instagram.
So, unless we have been
promised complete independence
and that they would actually
abide by our decisions
and follow our decisions,
I would not have done it.
So, it was basically Facebook's leadership
asking me to do this.
And we look very, very
carefully into whether
this would be an
institution that would be,
have that complete independence.
We'll lets definitely come to the
and test the independence
in just a moment if we can,
but are you comfortable
with the amount of power
Meta has overseeing Facebook,
Instagram, WhatsApp?
Yes and no.
I mean, I think social media
has been too unregulated
for too many years,
and obviously the Oversight Board
is not dealing with everything Meta.
There'll be tech discussions
and other discussions,
anti-trust discussions that
we are not dealing with,
we're dealing with content.
But there is absolutely no doubt
that until we started our work,
Meta was left too alone,
in terms of deciding on content,
whether content should
stay up or get removed,
making their own rules as they went along,
the transparency was missing.
It still is, and that is
why we need regulation.
And we need an oversight board.
What do you say to
those who are concerned,
that you are funded by
Facebook, to police Facebook?
Well, Facebook cannot interfere
in any of our decisions.
They have to live with our decisions.
When we decided on the case with,
regarding Trump, for example,
they had to follow our decisions.
And I don't talk to,
none of us talk to Facebook
about how we should decide anything.
So, it's up to each
and everyone to decide,
do they think that's independence?
I don't take any orders from Facebook.
You don't take any orders,
but you can't necessarily know
what they're not telling you.
No.
And for the world, you know,
the whistleblower Frances-
Yeah.
Haugen, came to people's attention.
She came and spoke aloud.
For instance, about that
high profile Facebook users,
got to follow different rules
and receive special treatment.
I mean, how could you
trust Facebook after that?
You have to trust Facebook to tell you.
No, we have to find a re-trust
in Facebook after that.
Because for example, on the crosschecks
that Haugen was talking about,
there's no doubt that we
didn't know enough about that,
which we have criticized
Meta for not telling us,
sufficiently clear
about these crosschecks.
Also when we asked about it,
we didn't get sufficient answers.
So, this is something we
are going to follow up on.
And I think, just the fact we have existed
for a little more than a year now,
has shed some light on
the lack of transparency.
The crosschecks, the fact
that they don't talk about
these things in public,
and other aspects of the lack
of transparency with Meta.
So, I do think that...
Where you were annoyed when you saw
what Frances had to say?
I was, I, yeah, some of it, yes.
I was annoyed, when I found
out that the crosschecks
that we had been asking Meta about,
they had not given fulfilling
answer to our questions.
What do you mean
crosschecks, sorry, when you?
Crosschecks is what they do with these,
high profile individuals,
Right.
That has an account.
Where there seem to be special rules
for high profile individuals.
And you hadn't been told about that?
We had not been told about it.
And when we asked in the
context of the Trump case,
that we looked at,
Yes.
They didn't give us a fulfilling answer,
which we have criticized also publicly.
So this, I think actually
underlines that you're right.
We don't know what we don't know.
But gradually, when Meta is
forced to open up more to us
and then also...
But by a whistle-blower?
Yeah, but that's absolutely,
but that's why it's good
to have whistle-blowers.
But I also think, our role here
is to keep asking those questions.
We've also asked Frances
Haugen afterwards,
we had interviews with her
because we invited her to talk...
So you have spoken to her.
We have spoken to her yeah.
And we're probably going
to speak to her again.
So, we have spoken to her
and the Oversight Board
to get even more information.
And we will continue to talk to anyone
who's got anything to say about Meta,
that we think will help us in our work,
and learn from that and
feed that back to Facebook.
But knowing that you have been misled.
I wouldn't call it misled.
I think that's your word, not mine.
Okay, so what word would you?
They didn't tell us the full picture.
They didn't give us a full-
Okay.
Picture of the crosschecks.
Knowing that you've been left in the dark-
Yeah.
Over some things,
is that a better-
Yeah.
Way of putting it?
Yeah, it's details.
How do you then trust Facebook?
Do you trust Facebook?
I think Facebook should
be much more transparent
with the Oversight Board,
but also with the general public,
which is actually more important.
And I believe, that the
work that I'm part of,
in the Oversight Board,
will have that effect.
But, do you trust them?
You're the co-chair of the board.
Yeah, I trust Facebook that
they give us the information
that we're asking for.
Even though they haven't?
I don't think they were
completely aware that they didn't,
but that's a different question,
and we have criticized them for it.
And there will be other
things in the future...
Why did you think they
left you in the dark?
I don't know, you have to ask Meta that,
but I think the most
important, you asked me,
do I trust Facebook?
I trust Facebook generally,
but that doesn't mean that
they will in this instance,
but also further on down the line,
there will be more areas
where we will criticize Meta.
We criticize Meta,
every time we take a decision on anything.
We have already issued more than
80 recommendations for Meta.
And we will keep doing that.
We push them hard on some of these issues.
So, I don't need to trust Meta completely.
I need to trust that they
give us the information,
and they answer our questions
truthfully, which I do.
But I think that that will
actually result in Meta treating
their users better, and being
more transparent in general.
Should Mark Zuckerberg still be in charge?
I think it would be very
wrong of me as a co-chair
of the Oversight Board to
start having opinions about
who leads Meta.
So, I will refrain from
getting into that discussion.
I will not do that,
because I think it will it'll mix up
what the role of the Oversight Board is-
Okay.
Which is to look at the content.
Fair enough, I get that.
I just wondered if you-
Yeah.
If you did have a view,
I know you've got a lot of opinions-
Yes, I've got a lot of opinions.
I'll tell you something people
do have a huge opinion about.
You mentioned it briefly,
but I want to just get a little
bit more into the detail.
Almost a year ago, to the day really,
Facebook decided to suspend-
Yeah.
President Trump for sharing
a video of his support,
to his supporters.
Some of his supporters
were storming the Capitol.
You upheld that view,
that decision to suspend him indefinitely,
but not permanently, is that right?
It was a very interesting situation.
Where Facebook had decided to, now Meta,
decide to remove Trump from the platforms,
based on the fact that
he was inciting violence.
And they asked us whether
that was, the Oversight Board,
whether that was the right decision.
That was one of, not one of the decisions
where user complaints,
it was actually Meta
asking the Oversight Board,
what we thought about this.
And we agreed with Meta that they,
it was okay to remove Mr. Trump
on the basis that he
was inciting violence,
but we disagreed with the
sanction that Meta had given.
So, we asked them actually to go back
and find a new sanction for Mr. Trump.
So, it became more case about
Meta and an arbitrary sanction,
than it was about Mr. Trump.
So it was sorting out the system,
as well as taking a view-
Yes.
On that.
Yeah.
I understand that.
But, some people did view that
as anti-democratic, you know,
75 million people voted for him.
Yeah.
And Facebook is in the situation where
it offers everybody the platform.
And I suppose, what would
you say to those people
who say, "He has a right
to be on Facebook"?
The most positive thing about social media
is that, and we forget that sometimes
when we discuss social media,
is that people have been given a voice
where they otherwise
would not have a voice,
agency, and so many people
can actually gather,
make groups, create demonstration,
be together on social media,
where before they didn't have a voice.
So, that's the most amazing
thing about social media.
And of course, politicians
should be on social media
because it's also their way
of connecting with people.
And they have, certainly
have a right to free speech.
So, I don't think it was
easy for Meta to decide
whether Mr Trump should
be taken down or not.
And we actually also touched
upon in our decision,
that Trump should not be taken down
because he was saying
falsehoods about the elections,
that he was not speaking the truth
about the election results.
We only said that it was
right to take Mr. Trump down
because he was inciting violence.
And within Facebook's own rules,
you can't incite violence.
I've got the right to speak,
but I don't have the right to speak,
if I'm actually inciting
violence against you
or anyone else.
So that, is where we
have to draw a balance.
And I, we thought that Meta
did that in the right place.
But of course, Mr. Trump has
the right to be on Facebook
and Instagram, if he
does not incite violence.
When's he coming back then?
I don't know, you have to ask Meta that.
Is there a date?
I don't know, they've given him,
I think gave him two years
or something like that.
Yes.
So you have to ask Meta.
He'll be back in time,
potentially for another
run at the White House.
We'll see.
That's up to Meta.
We will see, and then you'll
look at it, of course.
So that's part of the, of how
it works as we're learning.
Is Facebook a platform, or a publisher?
It's a platform in my view.
'Cause it sounds terribly
like a publisher.
Do you think?
As an editor, in the
way you just described
that view of Donald Trump.
I don't think so.
Because anyone who creates
a platform where people
can be part of it, they
have created some rules.
So, I do think it's good they
have the community standards.
They're actually really good,
the community standards that they have.
The problem is that they're
not always followed,
but the community standards are good, so.
When you said that decision,
sorry to interrupt.
But you said that decision
about Donald Trump,
just to go back to how you put it,
was not made by the community.
It was actually by Meta, it wasn't by,
you know, users coming forward.
So that to me, you know, as a journalist
brings to mind an editor,
sitting in a room saying,
"Well, I don't think that's
okay for us to publish".
Yeah, but I don't.
That is a key tension that
has been about Facebook,
for a long time.
And of course, if it admitted
to being a publisher,
it would be subject to
very different rules.
Yes.
So, you don't accept
that characterization?
I don't think Meta is a publisher,
I don't think they see
themselves as a publisher.
But they are taking responsibility-
And I would also question-
For the content.
Whether they should, they
are, which they should do.
And I think we also have to
find a new way of seeing that.
That's why, there's no doubt
it would need regulation
very much like what we have...
But you sound like editors.
Your board, you said you
only look at content.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, I can
see what your saying.
Where does it tip over into,
not into being a platform
and not being a publisher?
What keeps you....
Well, I think we're well past the point
where you can just be a platform.
Because you have to have rules,
because otherwise it just goes crazy.
You will have...
You'll have to take responsibility
for what's being published.
More or less, yeah you have
to take some responsib-,
but doesn't mean that
doesn't make you a publisher
in the old understanding of the word.
But that's, isn't that Facebook, or Meta
having it's cake and eating it?
I don't think so,
I think they are completely
entitled to have their standards
for what they want for, on their platform.
Regulators, of course, entitled
to now regulate the area.
I think we also have to ask the question.
Do we want social media
to be a publisher?
No, but that's the whole point,
a lot of people don't.
But...
Which is why they want Donald
Trump back on Facebook.
Which I think is a fair point of view.
But do we want-
They don't want Mark Zuckerberg
as the Editor-in-Chief.
But do we want social media to then be,
you could put anything on it.
But the laws haven't kept to pace.
So, if you look at the law
governing this, US law,
this section 230, excuse me -
states "Social media companies,
shouldn't be responsible for information
produced by someone else."
which means a user can
publish what they want,
and that Facebook isn't liable.
So, which is it?
You know, you sort of Facebook
is being liable sometimes,
and isn't other times.
It's very confusing.
But I think what you're asking
is really underlining
that we need regulation,
but also underlining that
you can't take social media,
which exists in all shapes and sizes,
in many different countries,
all over the world, and
squeeze it in to a regulation
that was for the-
The previous times.
Yeah, previous and
other centuries outlets.
Do you come down on the side broadly,
taking a step back,
coming away from the detail,
that social media is a force for good?
I do actually,
and I think we sometimes forget it,
because people are asking really,
really harsh questions,
and demanding more transparency
and criticizing Meta
and social media.
And twitter and other companies of course.
And fairly so.
But I think we sometimes forget,
would we like to go back to a world
where we didn't have social media?
Where we couldn't connect
with each other on,
on WhatsApp, for example.
Or communicate with each other,
get in contact with each other.
And also, being that when I was CEO
of Save the Children International,
I met so many people across the world,
in refugee camps and women
who want to organize,
labour organize, or organize
for micro-banking, or whatever.
And they could not do these things,
without being able to
connect via social medias.
Black Lives Matter,
Me Too movement, I could go on.
Of course they would exist,
and there were movements
before social media.
But when you weigh it up,
I do think that social
media is a force for good.
But, we're not there yet.
I wonder, are you grateful
you didn't grow up with social media?
Well, I think no,
I loved my childhood,
and I liked the simplicity of
my childhood, I really did.
But I also think when you
look at young people today,
I have two kids.
We have two kids, they're 25 and 22.
Honestly, I think that they
know more about the world.
They're cleverer, they
are better than we were.
We also have an individual responsibility
as parents to bring our children up,
but also children growing up to teach them
how to be people in the
world that we have now.
So I don't, I think we must be very,
very careful not to paint this
in black and white and say,
"Everything was just better".
I know that's not what you're doing-
No, but...
Everything was better in the old days,
because there's so many good things,
particularly for people,
perhaps more marginalized
people in the rest of the world
being heard, that has
come of social media.
And I, I've met so many people who finally
has a voice because of social media.
And we must be careful
not only to judge this by
the narrow lens in a Western Nordic world,
because social media is
much, much bigger than that.
And also, I mean, just to say, you know,
the societal ills that
come out on social media
were not created by social media.
No.
It's a platform to see them
in a different way as well.
But I was just going to ask
you about something else as we,
our time together sort of comes to an end.
And it was about joylessness, and joy.
Because some feel taking it
from the perspective I am,
at the Western perspective,
I recognize that.
That the internet certainly did used to be
a bit more fun.
You know, you could share some jokes.
I mean, you still can obviously.
Yeah.
But people sort of allowed each other to,
to say things a bit
tongue-in-cheek, a bit sarcastic.
And I was just looking back,
and you took a selfie when
you were Prime Minister-
Yeah.
You know what I'm going to be saying.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But for everyone else, and you were at
Nelson Mandela's Memorial,
you were a Prime Minister.
And on one side was Barack Obama,
and on the other side was David Cameron.
And if I was you, I'd also be thinking,
this is an interesting selfie.
In the days before social distancing,
so you all crowd in and you have a selfie.
And some said, you know,
"This is not what you should
be doing at a memorial".
And actually you responded saying,
you know, "We're people, we are people."
Yeah.
And it was a joyful
occasion, in many ways.
It was a very joyful occasion.
It was a memorial,
but it was at a sports stadium,
and the south African, like
there was drums as music,
there was singing.
It was quite a joyous moment,
and almost a celebration-
Of his life.
Of his life, yeah.
We sat in the corner, all the
heads, states of government,
and David Cameron sort of
muscled in where I was sitting,
which was close to Obama.
We had a nice time.
Everyone was laughing and
I had not taken selfies
at this stage.
This was my first selfie ever.
Your first selfie-
Yeah.
Was with the President of America.
And I think there-
Okay.
The word actually came into the dictionary
that year because it became so famous.
And I just thought, "This
is where you take selfies".
So, I just learned to take
selfies from my oldest daughter.
It's quite an impressive first selfie.
It's quite good isn't it?
Yeah,
it's not very good, I'm
the only one who looks good
in that selfie, is actually me.
And so, but it's actually, it was fun,
but people did criticize it.
Because they thought it wasn't serious.
And it certainly wasn't serious.
And it was interesting to see
that we were just three people
in the moment.
I said, "Well it's good, to try this".
And it was like a new thing back then.
It sounded like David Cameron really tried
to get in that, you were just
doing that with Barack Obama.
It was quite funny because Michelle Obama
was just on the side-
Yeah.
If I remember correctly of the image
that was taken of you taking it.
Yeah.
Looking, you know, not in the
picture, just quite stern,
straight ahead. It was never
published, this selfie,
I don't think.
No, I've got it.
It's on my phone.
Have you framed it?
I have actually published,
because I wrote a book in,
no, I haven't framed it.
I've wrote a book in Denmark, in Danish.
And it is actually in there, so you can.
It's in there?
It's in there.
It's seen the light, okay-
Yeah.
I hadn't seen that,
but I suppose just really to
get your take around that,
which is that, you know,
there's a lot of hate,
people don't necessarily
see politicians as people.
And I just wonder, now
you're not one anymore.
You're still married to one,
but certainly you're not
a world leader anymore.
Do you think it's at our peril
that we don't see our leaders as people?
Yeah, I think it is.
And I always just want people
to calm down a little bit,
because we are all people and
we have got a private life.
I'm not talking about
being soft on politicians,
and not criticizing for
them, when they do things.
And I've been criticized a lot
and prime ministers
being criticized a lot.
So, that happens.
But maybe if we all
calm down a little bit,
also on social media,
we would just have, we will just be nicer.
And I think the rule should be,
that we try to treat
people on social media,
like we would talk to
each other when we met.
And people are very polite
to each other when they meet,
when they stand in the queue together,
when they take the tube, whatever.
And perhaps, we should
try and take a little bit
of that politeness into social media,
and the world would
actually be a better place.
Helle Thorning-Schmidt,
thank you very much.
Thank you so much for having me.
And thank you so much for being with us,
until we meet again,
mask up, stay safe and good-bye.